[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue vous avez attendu encore quelques
minutes avant de profiter du week-end de
l'ascension et vous avez bien fait car
nous avons ce soir le plaisir
d'accueillir jérôme sainte-marie bonsoir
jérôme vous êtes politologues sondeurs
vous avez créé votre propre aux sociétés
de sondages d'ailleurs pôle inbox et
vous êtes également essayiste votre
dernier livre bloc contre bloc la
dynamique du maquereau nisme a été
publié aux éditions du cerf puis bon
soir mathieu sous caire on est ravis de
vous accueillir vous êtes consultant
vous aussi vous avez votre propre
structure d'ailleurs vous êtes par
ailleurs expert associé à la fondation
jean jaurès et parmi vos diverses
expériences professionnelles
vous avez été le conseiller stratégie du
myriam el khomri qui était ministre du
travail on s'en souvient c'était pendant
le quinquennat de françois hollande et
les sondages parlons-en et plus
précisément de celui ci il a été publiée
ce matin dans le figaro c'est un sondage
ifop
et il se focalise sur les élections
régionales en provence alpes côte d'azur
vous vous souvenez évidemment de cette
espèce de 2,2 le psychodrame avec renaud
muselier essayant de faire une liste
commune avec la république en marche
puis finalement faisant demi tour même
si on ne sait toujours pas s'il y aura
ou non une liste en marche au premier
tour de la prochaine élection régionale
c'est au mois de juin
en revanche ce qui semble acquis c'est
que cette histoire a plutôt profité à
thierry mariani en tout cas si on en
croit notre sondage regarder ça ce sont
les résultats
c'est une projection bien sûr les
résultats aujourd'hui du premier tour
s'il avait lieu et le candidat du
rassemblement national thierry mariani
et à 36% y gagne 5 points
ce qui est intéressant c'est que renaud
muselier lui est toujours à 27 % ce qui
veut dire qu a priori il n'a pas
souffert de cette opération sauf que
elle semble avoir remobilisés d
jean qui s'abstenait jusque là dans les
sondages et qui seraient prêts à voter
mariani jérôme sainte-marie vous
m'engager comme salarié commentateurs de
sondages ou non c'est pas ça du tout
absolument autant plus que ça correspond
assez étroit trop quand même à ce
qu'elle dit frédéric dabi dans le figaro
du tour et qu'ils avaient en effet
toujours cité souligne chalet vérifier
bon effectivement ce que l'ifop rend
disponible ces sondages sur son site
je suis allé vérifier par rapport aux
sondages qui était fait il ya un mois à
peu près et effectivement on n'a pas
l'impression d'un transfert d'électeurs
notamment d'électeurs de droite qui se
serait dit finalement on est déçu on est
trahi par par muselier et on va vers la
liste est raide
il semblerait beau effectivement que ce
soit une sur mobilisation d'électeurs
qui regardait tout cela de loin qu'ils
ne savaient même pas forcément que les
élections régionales était proche et qui
là se disent mais finalement c'est
l'occasion peut-être d'envoyer d'envoyer
un sévère avertissement à gouvernement
au gouvernement alors faut bien juste un
petit point technique tout de même quand
on établit des sondages bien entendu on
interroge uniquement des gens inscrits
mais on sait que là que beaucoup
d'inscrits est de plus en plus n'iront
pas voter
donc on demande aux gens s'ils sont
inscrits mais aussi s'ils ont ils sont
sûrs d'aller voter
et généralement on a plutôt plus de
monde d'ailleurs que des gens qui vont
réellement aller voter donc on sans
limite aux gens qui nous déclarent être
sûrs d'aller voter
c'est une proportion bien sûr qui évolue
dans le temps et qui a tendance à
augmenter au fur à mesure qu'on se
rapproche du scrutin là mon avis a
augmenté ses les données sont pas
disponibles mais ça a dû augmenter
fortement
compte tenu du psychodrame qui a été mis
en scène dans cette région dernier point
j'ai essayé de regarder d'autres
sondages relatifs à cette région il ya
un sondage ipsos qui est intéressant en
ceci qu'il donne les priorités pour les
électeurs de paca est beaucoup plus
qu'ailleurs en france c'est la sécurité
et l'immigration
il ya eu en plus avignon qui comme je le
rappelle dans le vaucluse donc en paca
ces événements tragiques d'avignon et de
toute façon il ya toujours une
préoccupation particulière pour la
sécurité et l'immigration dans cette
région là et aussi à réseau national
bien placés dans cette autre sondage qui
est
cohérent avec celui que nous publions ce
matin voilà il aimait ça en relation
avec un troisième sondage cette fois ci
deux bébés à qui faisait le bilan de 4
ans de macron les deux thèmes sur lequel
le bilan est jugé le plus négatif par
les deux tiers des français contre 15%
je crois qu'ils le jugent positif c'est
précisément la sécurité et l'immigration
donc je crois que là-dessus c'est un
levier puissant pour amener au vote
contre le gouvernement
autrefois ce vote contre le gouvernement
au contre emmanuel macron pouvait
s'exprimer de manière diverse
aujourd'hui compte tenu de cette rumeur
d'accord entre l air et l air em
et bien ce qu'ils veulent sans que fait
le gouvernement non plus et qui sont de
sensibilité de droite n'ont plus
tellement d'autre choix que d'aller du
côté de me la liste mariani
je vous livre quelques résultats
complémentaires de ce sondage car en
fait nous avons testé diverses
hypothèses de second tour et
c'est thierry mariani qui semble
l'emporter
il ya une hypothèse dans al dans les
deux cas pardon soyons clairs dans les
deux cas il n'y a pas de liste l hérault
m au second tour on part donc du
principe que s'il ya une liste en marche
s'est pas encore sûr pour l'instant elle
se retire au profit de renaud muselier
et bien ça se passe de la façon suivante
le ration nationale arrive avec 38%
s'il y a une liste l air et une liste
europe ecologie les verts au second tour
38 % contre 34 à renaud muselier donc
c'est leur hymne national qui
l'emporterait et s'il ya une liste
commune parti socialiste europe écologie
les verts et bien c'est encore
mieux pour le rassemblement national qui
aurait 41%
c'est pour ça qu'on a posé cette
question un peu provocatrice est-ce que
leur assemblée nationale est-ce que
thierry mariani a déjà gagné cette
élection mathieu sous caire alors ce qui
est sûr c'est que toute la dynamique
poussent en ce sens toute la dynamique
poussent en ce sens mais je me souviens
quand même que pour les dernières
régionales celle de 2015
on assistait à une dynamique
relativement comparables la crainte
j'utilise ce terme que quatre régions
tombe dans l'escarcelle de l'extrême
droite marine le pen était déjà en lice
évidemment à l'époque et résultat des
courses alors à la faveur de deux
situations locales très particulière et
on se souvient en particulier de la
façon dont l'élection de xavier bertrand
dans les hauts de france c'était opérer
le rassemblement national n'avait à
l'époque raflé aucune grande région bon
là il ya quelque chose de tout à fait
intéressant effectivement paka paka
pourrait être un laboratoire de ce vers
quoi nous pourrions aller dans quelques
mois et c'est tout à fait déterminant
parce que marine le pen contrairement à
ce qu'on dit n'est pas aussi forte que
ça dans la séquence la fondation jean
jaurès que j'ai l'honneur de représenter
ici a produit une note tout à fait
intéressante il est quelques semaines
pour illustrer le fait que la victoire
de marine le pen était possible avec 3,3
trois paramètres permettant de
déterminer un la porosité très grande à
un niveau inédit entre l'électorat des
républicains l'électorat du
rassemblement national
la dédiabolisation marine le pen réussit
et troisième élément un rejet
extrêmement fort des manuels macron le
meilleur allié de marine le pen en
l'espèce c'est emmanuel macron la note
10 bien qu'une élection de marine le pen
est possible mais elle ne dit pas
qu'elle est probable et l'élection de
marine le pen n'est pas probable
l'epa probable en 2022 au président 2022
aux présidentielles parce que en
particulier un le niveau auquel elle se
situe aujourd'hui en réalité est
inférieur au niveau qui était le sien à
un an de la présidentielle 2017
elle est forte elle est remontée mais
elle était elle était tombé tellement
bas après l'élection présidentielle et
en particulier son débat raté de
l'entre-deux-tours que son niveau actuel
n'est pas aussi élevé repas
je reviens pas cas oui mais justement je
guéris mariani s'est pas marine le pen
c'est un homme qui a été ministre sous
nicolas sarkozy il fait pas peut-être ce
qui fait moins peur que marine le pen à
certains électeurs
oui alors encore une fois on est dans un
bastion historique du front national on
sait que le sud de la france c'est un
bastion historique
en réalité vous avez deux front national
ou de rassemblement national
vous avez un rassemblement national
identitaire qui est celui du sud de la
france qui constitue encore une fois un
bastion historique de la droite la plus
extrême
et puis vous avez un deuxième front
national dans le nord où la question
sociale passe devant la question
identitaire je vais un peu vite mais ce
ne sont pas exactement sa taille on pas
déjà pour le coup je n'invente pas c'est
en particulier la latf en tout cas là la
distinction coopèrerait le bras avec un
électorat dans la sociologie aux abords
du stade ça doit être pour ça et les
précipations élévation et on voit bien
que du coup on a en paca un électorat
qui est mouvant entre les républicains
et le rassemblement national et qui
pourrait effectivement rejoindre celui
qui paraît fréquentable parce qu'il fut
il y à peu encore une fois un sarkozyste
bon et est d'ailleurs un proche de
renaud muselier il n'empêche que il
n'est plus là il n'est plus là et il
n'empêche que une victoire 2-1 mariani
aujourd'hui donnerait un élan
considérable à la campagne
présidentielle de marine le pen parce
que je voulais revenir juste sur ce
point marine le pen n'est aujourd'hui
pas si haute que cela est deuxième
faiblesse de marine le pen elle est
mauvaise en campagne elle a toujours été
mauvaise en campagne ils se trouvent et
gagna une région la crédibilité il se
trouve que l a toujours fini plus bas
qu'elle n'a démarré je vous verrai
mauvaise en campagne et là évidemment
pas qu'à pourrait la mettre sur orbite
de façon décisive et nos internautes
sont assez partagés parce que vous savez
que on aime beaucoup vous poser des
questions on voulait pose sur tous les
supports possibles
en tout cas sur twitter et sur youtube
sur twitter vous êtes 53 % à considérer
que non tu ailles mariani n'a pas déjà
gagné les régionales toute façon
évidemment c'est vrai est factuellement
puisque l'élection n'a pas eu lieu mais
vous savez que c'est une sorte
d'exercice de projection alors qu'il ya
une majorité inverse sur youtube avec 61
% de oui
quelques réactions celle de did not qui
considère que ma gagné arrivera sûrement
en tête au premier tour mais qu'il lui
reste encore un mode campagne au cours
duquel tout peut arriver
nicole 06 j'habite en paca et je crois
que pour une fois je voterai et rennes
marre des magouilles d'estrosi et de
muselier alors est ce qu'il ya vraiment
eu des magouilles
est-ce que renaud muselier et c'est à ce
point trompé écoutez la façon dont ils
se justifient ce matin sur france bleu
azur
il explique que lui il fait une liste lr
et puis si des gens veulent venir avec
lui m'a tant mieux mais qu'il n'y a pas
d'alliance je suis mandaté par ma
famille politique pour faire en sorte
que avec mes listes je puisse faire en
sorte que je représentais majorité
régionale composée de ses huit
composantes dans lequel il ya des
repreneurs dans la majorité
présidentielle
et puis parce qu'à faire ça veut dire la
majorité présidentielle dans cette liste
fait de la jirs du modem de des élus de
la rmr lrm finalement il n'y a pas de
ministre il n'y a pas de parlementaires
voilà c'est clair jérôme sainte-marie
non aux rives et j'ai craint que ce soit
très clair très peur si vous voulez
c'est qu'ici ce que c'est tout ça n'est
pas très sérieux
c'est vrai que c'est ahurissant si vous
voulez dans une période où les gens on
est très forte préoccupation de voir à
ciel ouvert ces négociations et ses
arguties il ya un ministre de ministre
quel sens ça s'il n'y a pas de listes
les rues aime les gens auront bien
compris qui aura une fusion de listes
enfin c'est quelque chose assez
formidable je voudrais rebondir ce cadet
mathieu soupière pour déjà produire je
suis d'accord sur un point important
c'est à dire qu'effectivement le score
actuel de la liste mariani n'est pas si
exceptionnel que cela au fond en 2015 la
liste marion maréchal avait réalisé 45%
des suffrages exprimés au premier tour
et elle avait ensuite plafonné à laver
tangente et les 45%
on se rappelle qu'à l'époque la liste l
air était seul au second tour puisque
les socialistes s'étaient retirés
c'était à l'époque christophe castaner
qui dirigeait le voilà ils ont été à la
terreur c'était une campagne assez
réussie femme très réussie de marion
maréchal qui a même gagné près de 800
mille voix je crois entre les deux tours
mais la dramatisation a été telle que l
avait été très largement battue alors là
il ya quand même des différents cassé je
vous concède ce point mais cependant il
ya des différences assez sensible qui
font que le jeu reste très ouvert pour
cette élection alors première différence
importante c'est que vous allez avoir en
principe le candidat de droite le
président sortant sera au second tour or
il va être associé au pouvoir en place
la dernière fois c'était pas ça du tout
c'était une liste qui étaient contre le
pouvoir en place qui était en 2015 on
était donc à l'époque de françois
hollande est donc pour un électeur on
pouvait voter à la fois contre le
racisme nationale et contre le pouvoir
en place qui était très impopulaire
là c'est plus possible c'était christian
estrosi la tête de liste christian
estrosi va lever le risque des mois et
dont on ne l'avait pas dit donc ce match
n'aurait rien que je n'infirme pas non
merci
et donc là c'est très différent parce
que là si vous vous laissez il simplifie
le choix à mon avis à ses dépens ou soit
vous votez pour quelqu'un qui
doit être qui sera à droite mais qui
sera à droite pas tant que ça parce que
ça sera matinée de maquereaux nisme
parce qu'il ya des inconvénients
parce que d'une part beaucoup de gens de
droite vont se dire ben non moi je suis
tellement préoccupé par la l'immigration
et la sécurité que je peux pas voter
pour une liste qui soutient à pouvoir
qui à mes yeux a échoué sur ces points
là et puis pour les gens de gauche ça va
être compliqué aussi si vous voulez de
se reporter sur quelqu'un qui incarne à
la fois la droite et un pouvoir macro ni
ce qui n'est pas forcément si populaire
que cela donc ça ça rend les choses
compliquées l'autre point alors là je
sors un peu des sondages
c'est la question du retrait de la liste
de gauche d'après le sondage ifop et
plus encore d'après sondage ipsos une
liste de gauche pourrait franchir la
barre de 10 % à 10 % comme vous savez on
peut se maintenir
est ce que aujourd'hui il serait
possible que cette liste fasse hara kiri
parce que ça a été terrible
en 2015 il a fallu dans les hauts de
france et en paca la liste se retire se
retirer ça veut dire une version
radicale le front républicain ça veut
dire ne plus avoir un seul élu
ça fait des moyens politiques et des
moyens financiers au moins à ma
connaissance messieurs castaner qui est
passé ensuite pour un euro delà du front
républicain ne voulait pas se retirer et
ça lui est imposé par le pouvoir
socialiste qui lui a dit à l'époque le
parti socialiste est fort on te trouvera
des compensations
et puis après comme il l'a raconté on
l'a oublié il se plaint que cambadélis
n'est pas appelée et c est assez déçu il
s'est rallié très rapidement emmanuel
macron quand celui ci est apparu
aujourd'hui vous n'êtes pas un pouvoir
d'un parti de gauche écologistes
socialistes ou encore moins france
insoumise capable d'imposer à une liste
locale de dire bah tant pis ou
n'auraient pas de siège
vous avez fait 15% vous avez fait
campagne
c'est pas grave vous vous retirer je
crains s'il voulait que le pouvoir des
partis de gauche aujourd'hui parisien ne
soit pas suffisant pour imposer un
retrait à des listes de gauche
or la gauche effectivement souffre
encore localement de ces retraits on le
voit très bien d'ailleurs on peut revoir
donc une triangulaire ça avantage
marianne ils vont avoir une autre image
aussi il y a au second tour
trois listes et bien thierry mariani ils
l'emportent probablement parce qu'il ya
une forme de dispersion des voix qui lui
qui lui profite
un autre sujet si vous le voulez bien
que nous pouvons traiter aujourd'hui
mais avant je voudrais vous citer
d'autres commentaires d'internautes
excusez moi mais je les découvre en même
temps que vous et ils sont intéressants
d'abord chardons bleus qui nous rappelle
qu'aucune élection n'est gagnée avant
les résultats du scrutin vous avez bien
raison et puis au minium qui estime
qu'en provence
le rassemblement national est différent
de ce qu'il est dans les autres régions
car il est beaucoup plus agressif
c'est un point de vue et puis aussi
celui de général escape quand on voit
les autres candidats à leurs magouilles
leur absence de programmes leur
clientélisme mariani mériterait de
gagner deux fils mais évidemment il y
aura un bar alger pour écouter on en
reparlera sûrement d'ici l'élection oui
l'autre sujet dont on vous propose de
parler c'est celui de cette candidate la
république en marche elle s'appelle
sarah zemma me elle est candidate non
pas aux régionales et aux élections
départementales
car vous savez qu'il va y avoir deux
élections en même temps le mois prochain
elle est candidate la république en
marche dans un canton de montpellier et
sur une affiche
elle apparaît voilée tout ça n'est pas
passé inaperçu loin de là il ya d'abord
eu un tweet de jordan bardella le vice
président du rassemblement national
protestants et puis il ya eu ça peut
être plus surprenant ça disent las des
rennais qui a re tweeté la déclaration
de jordan bardella et qui a expliqué que
son parti ne soutiendrait pas cette
candidate si elle persistait à se
montrer vous allez sur les documents de
campagne
ça discute ça ternit un peu gêné quand
même 2 semblait courir en quelque sorte
derrière bardet la regarder c'était sur
rtl hier et évidemment je n'ai pas à
prisa par un tweet du journal bardella
et je vais vous dire si j'ai un regret
dans cette affaire c'est d'avoir répondu
à chantal bardet la voilà je vais vous
dire les choses simplement parce que à
aucun moment j'ai été touché par les
messages que j'ai reçus
aucun moment je ne veux laisser penser
qu'il puisse y avoir la moindre
collusion danser entre ce que nous
défendons la république en marche est ce
que porte le rassemblement national
c'est un peu anecdotique parce que on
peut re tweeté le message de quelqu'un
sans forcément partager son point de vue
sauf que sur le fond en marche a dit ben
oui on ne peut pas on ne doit pas être
une candidate affichant un signe
religieux ostentatoire comme il est
convenu de dire quand on est candidat à
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce point
de vue mathieu souquet or s'il s'agit de
répondre à la question de savoir si je
suis choqué par exemple non je ne suis
pas choqué par le fait que quelqu'un
porte le voile qu'une femme porte le
voile et qu'elle puisse il me semble que
c'est un élément d'intégration que de ce
que de se présenter à des élections ça
donc j'ai vu une personne encore une
fois représentant une minorité
religieuse en l'occurrence porte un
voile assume cela et se présente devant
les devant les électeurs je n'ai pas de
problème avec ça de la même façon que
encore une fois le voile dans l'espace
public ne me choque pas pas davantage
que la kippa ou la tenue du la tenue du
bouddhistes ou et je suis donc vous
pensez qu'en marche à tort de de menacer
de retirer sont investis à l'or non je
pense que le débat et je pense que le
débat est légitime
je pense que ça vaut le coup de se poser
la question c'est pour ça qu'on est là
ouais je pense qu'on devrait j'ai mon
point de vue sur le sujet mais je pense
qu'on devrait pouvoir avoir aujourd'hui
sur la laïcité
un débat qui soit à peu près serein et
non polémiques or on n'y parvient pas
est ce que ça démontre c'est que tous
les partis ou à peu près buts sur la
question de la laïcité se fracture sur
cette question de la laïcité c'est très
vrai à gauche c'est très vrai chez les
écolos c'est très vrai chez une partie
de la droite une partie de la droite
seulement le seul camp qui aujourd'hui
est relativement fourni autour de la
question de la laïcité c'est l'extrême
droite c'est tout à fait baroque c'est
tout à fait paradoxale l'extrême droite
est historiquement idéologiquement
contre la laïcité elle s'est construite
contre la laïcité elle a combattu la
laïcité est elle devient elle se
présente aujourd'hui encore une fois
comme la meilleure défonceuse de la
laïcité et même derrière la laïcité
comme la meilleure marine le pen comme
meilleure garante des droits des femmes
face à la domination masculine ce qu'il
a encore fait rire qu'à l'extrême droite
ne s'est pas distingué dans son histoire
par son combat en faveur des valeurs
féministes
il ya là une femme candidate à
l'élection présidentielle
pardon à une femme candidate à
l'élection présidentielle cette ce oui
sa programmation politique c'est un
progrès absolument c'est pas la première
la première femme candidate à la
présidentielle dans l'histoire c'est
arlette laguiller en 1974 à une époque
où sept français sur dix pensaient que
une femme à l'elysée était une très
mauvaise idée
voilà donc les évidemment la société
progresse et le front national lui même
progrès sur certaines valeurs c'est
incontestable jérôme sainte-marie notre
question est un peu provocatrice comme
souvent ce que vous êtes choqués ou
plutôt est ce que vous considérez que
c'est anormal compte tenu de ce qu'est
la république française qu'une femme se
présente voilée sur un document de
campagne lors sont un sujet aussi
délicat et n'étant pas très courageux je
suis derrière deux auteurs le premier
c'est un probablement rafael dos ans qui
a sorti un excellent bout livre qui
s'appelle le rêve de l'assimilation et
qui m'a fait comprendre qu'en fait ces
questions là sont pas des cas probables
de laïcité c'est des problèmes
d'assimilation parce que c'est pas un
prêtre de laïcité vous pouvez très bien
vous présenter depuis toujours avec des
signes religieux d'ailleurs des prêtres
à commencer par l'abbé pierre est siéger
à l'assemblée nationale en costume fin
dans leurs costumes traditionnels du
prêtre à l'époque
eh bien vous avez l'état d'épidémie et
donc ensuite vous avez des partis
démocrates chrétiens ça n'a jamais
choqué personne n'est parti
chrétien-démocrate du côté de
rambouillet notamment donc pourquoi pas
c'est quelque chose qui n'a rien à voir
quelle laïcité de l'état
le problème qui nous choque la c1
problèmes d'assimilation
est-ce que c'est conforme aux moeurs
tout simplement on parle plus comme ça
maintenant mais c'est ce qu'on ressent
en réalité aux moeurs du pays alors moi
je suis allé voir également un autre
auteur et je vous recommande d'ailleurs
c'est un excellent blog de droite
électorale s'appelle un monsieur qui
s'appelle romain à rambo qui un jeune
juriste jeune avocat qui a traité la
question justement aujourd'hui et qui a
rappelé alors je sais pas si c'est une
décision un avis pour le conseil d'état
de 2010 qui dit je le cite aucune norme
constitutionnelle et notamment pas le
principe de laïcité n'impose que soient
exclus du droit de se porter candidat à
des élections des personnes qui
entendraient à l'occasion de cette
candidature faire état de leurs
convictions religieuses
le conseil d'état est donc très clair on
peut se présenter en manifestant sa foi
qu'elle
soit donc ce n'est pas quelque chose qui
relève de la laïcité ou de la république
c'est quelque chose qui relève de la
simulation et de la culture française
est pris également du modèle de société
et d'après ce que nie ce juriste on a un
robot c'est pas du tout à l'état sont
maintenant les candidatures ont été
déposées pour les départementales le 5
mai c'est plus l'état qui est en cause
c'est pas la justice par tout ça le seul
qui sont en cause désormais c'est la
république en marche est-ce qu'il
maintienne ou pas leur investiture à
cette équipe
pas seulement à cette dame du coup ça va
toucher tout le toubib noseda binub et
le binôme suppléant donc ces quatre
personnes étaient hier soir et entrant
le précise voilà ce qu'elle peut se
réclamer mars avait difficile de refuser
pour l'instant refusé au binôme donc à
mon avis est ce qu'ils disent bon tant
pis quand on se sera pas pour nous on
refuse c'est une question de principe au
niveau national en plus où les deux
sujets sont calmes à ses proches à ses
connexes les deux sujets qu'on aborde là
on voit bien que cette image fait du
tort encore davantage à la liste
muselier si elle est soutenue par la
réplique en marche
donc effectivement il ya des gens qui
trouvent qui s'inquiète la présence de
l'islam qui s'inquiète d'un modèle
multiculturaliste et qui ne veulent pas
ce genre de choses c'est entièrement
leurs droits et maintenant il s'agit de
savoir pour la république en marche où
elle en est est ce qu'elle veut après un
projet assimilationniste où est ce
qu'ils valent un projet à l'anglo
saxonne multiculturaliste si vous voulez
mon avis je pense que la réplique en
marche dans ses cadres et profondément
anglo saxonne dans ses références
profondément multiculturaliste pour elle
c'est un progrès puisque ces américains
et inversément mais je crois un peu leur
problème c'est que pour la plupart des
électeurs c'est pas ça du tout il
demeure attaché un modèle que je ne
qualifierais pas de républicains tous
très bien votre multiculturelle
républicain un modèle qui est tout
simplement dans la tradition française
et dans une tradition d'assimilation à
un certain nombre de moeurs
vous dites que appliquant marché plutôt
multiculturelle ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'il ya quand même un certain
nombre de ses leaders
je pense à marlène schiappa je pense à
jean michel blanquer r je pense à la
députée roberge et qu'elles ne sont pas
sur cette ligne d'où le débat interne
vous chers internautes vous êtes plutôt
choquée par le fait qu'une candidate
soit voilé sur une affiche de campagne
etes-vous choqué vous nous répondez oui
à 70%
la question est posée sur twitter vous
pouvez d'ailleurs continuer à y répondre
voici quelques commentaires seb nous dit
elle est présidente de l'association
tabac ça c'est une association
semble-t-il qui effectivement a des
idées qui serait proche de celle des
frères musulmans
elles recrutent les frères musulmans et
tariq ramadan ajoute seb je suis plutôt
choqué de la voir sur une liste en
marche
denis considère qu'un élu ne doit pas
afficher de façon ostentatoire son
appartenance ethnique ou religieuse à la
peut-être qu'un candidat aussi et puis
babineau sur la forme c'est maladroit de
la part de guérini mais sur le fond il
ya un vrai débat sur le voile au sein de
la république en marche dernier
commentaire celui de nini une candidate
voilée oui ça me choque alors il y à un
commentaire une prise de position
on n'a pas encore entendu celle de jean
luc mélenchon mais ce qu'on sait c'est
que j'en ai plein champ a pris position
à plusieurs reprises pour dire bah non
c'est pas choquant d'avoir le voile dans
l'espace public par exemple pour les
accompagnatrices scolaire or il n'a pas
toujours penser ça et vous faisiez
allusion
jérôme sainte-marie à une décision du
conseil d'état de 2010 cette décision
elle fait suite à une autre candidature
de ce type
c'était sur une liste du nouveau parti
anticapitaliste le parti d'olivier
besancenot
c'était aux régionales de 2010 et il y
avait là aussi une candidate voilée
affaire révélée par votre excellente
consoeur sophie de ravinel absolument
dans le figaro et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que jean luc mélenchon à l'époque
il n'était pas du tout d'accord avec ce
genre de pratiques
regardez c'est une archive que nous
avons retrouvé une interview à public
sénat du 3 février 2010 20 noeuds soit
lorsque l'on veut être élu je veux que
tout le monde l'entende allait bien il
faut pouvoir représenter tout le monde
c'est donc une erreur de se présenter à
des élections en affichant une
appartenance religieuse qui rend
impossible cette représentation du
souverain dans son ensemble quand vous
entendez cet argument mathieu sous caire
vous qui n'êtes pas choqué est ce que
vous vous
vous dites la gauche a changé et c'est
sans doute mieux comme ça alors je suis
pas du tout le porte parole il défenseur
de jean luc mélenchon mais il n'y a
aucune contradiction entre cette
déclaration la et des déclarations plus
récentes
là en l'occurrence jean luc mélenchon
point effectivement une candidate aux
élections
je sais pas ce qu'il a dit là
considèrent concernant le la sphère de
la république en clair là dessus donc
c'est parfait
oui mais donc comment encore cette fois
on sait accompagner une sortie scolaire
et être candidat aux élections pour le
compte de la république c'est pas la
même chose donc je vois pas du tout de
contradictions dans les différents
propos que jean luc mélenchon aurait pu
tenir
je crois qu'il est assez constant au
contraire sur ces sujets-là en locales
auront une autre déclaration toujours
sur le voile de jean luc mélenchon
celle-là est récente elle date du 12
février 2021 et vraiment on a ce
sentiment que le voile ne lui pose pas
de problème qu'on regarde pas le voile
dans l'espace public qui à mes joueurs
redonne la parole je rêvais et comme l'a
dit un de mes collègues qui est pas sur
mais bon il a dit ce qui compte c'est
parce qu'elles ont sur la tête c'est ce
qu'elles ont dans la tête exactement et
pardon de vous dire que les jeunes
femmes françaises qui sont de culture
musulmane
les autres qui sont là aussi ah mais
elles ont pas elles n'acceptent pas
qu'on leur donne des ordres elles sont
capables de se révéler si elles ne
veulent pas les appliquer donc un peu de
respect pour les gens tant que mathieu
se casse mélenchon dit mais il le
problème c'est parce qu'elles sont sur
la tête et donc a priori devrait pas
poser de problème qu'elle se présente
aux élections avec un voile mais encore
une fois le voile dans l'espace public
je vois pas par l'extrême droite qui est
unanimement et résulte heureuse
résolument contre pardon il ya des tas
de gens que ça ne choque pas n'est ce
pas celui qui s'était largement cité me
permets d'apporter un témoignage
personnel
j'habite dans le nord est de paris entre
la gare du nord et barbes un quartier
qui depuis toujours et composé d'une
forte minorité maghrébine
je croise depuis que j'y vis et
d'ailleurs depuis que j'y suis enfant
des hommes en djellaba et des femmes
effectivement voile et je ne suis pas du
tout choquée par ce papa par cette
présence là et et je rebondis sur ce que
disait jérôme sainte-marie tout à
l'heure je ne vois aucune opposition
entre le fait qu'une femme porte un
voile et squatte assimilés je crois que
en aucun cas c'est le voit du débat le
voile est l' indice du nom
assimilation je pense que des femmes
voilées pratiquant l'islam de façon
douce et tranquille peuvent se sentir
pleinement intégré pleinement partie
prenante de la république française
comme encore une fois pendant très
longtemps des personnes très investie
dans la religion catholique ont pu
conjuguer et leur foi
et encore une fois le respect de
principes collectifs je ne vois aucune
difficulté face à cela quelques instants
pour répondre sur ce sujet là qui est
celui du fonds ont finalement est ce que
est ce que c'est des choix personnel ou
est ce que c'est une manifestation
politique de de ce qui pourrait être un
rejet des deux de nos principes de vie
je pense tout en se présentant aux
élections je comprends bien la gamme
tradition parce que c'est la seconde la
seconde situation
alors c'est plutôt un point de vue
justement être opposés au voile n'est
pas du tout un point de vue d'extrême
droite c'est même dans le monde arabe un
point de vue généralement de gauche et
notamment de la famille communiste alors
devant un point commun elles jean luc
mélenchon sait qu on vient tous les ans
nés tous les deux nés au maghreb l'ue au
maroc - algérie et qu'on a gardé tous
les deux un attachement et des liens
avec ces pays là et il sait comme moi
que à quel point l'arrivée du voile non
pas du voile traditionnelle mais du
voile importés en quelque sorte des
pratiques apportées notamment est promue
par le les émirats et dont qui amène un
nouveau voile voile que portent les
maghrébines actuellement n'est pas du
tout le voile porté leur grand-mère est
bien seul ceci est une manifestation qui
finalement s'est transformé en comment
dirais-je une imposition sur les jeunes
femmes qui ne voulait pas le porter et
derrière il ya un modèle politique qui
est un modèle de l'islamisme politique
c'est pas comment dirais-je un moment
donné il ya les principes ya les débats
et puis à l'observation courante
l'observation courant dans tous les pays
arabes et notamment des pays fortement
après comme empreint de culture
républicaine et françaises comme l'était
le maroc la tunisie ou l'algérie
on a bien vu l'évolution on a bien vu ce
que cela a signifié pour les femmes pour
la société toute entière s'est
d'ailleurs paradoxalement is que c'est
rentré fait paradoxal que la gauche aux
accents gauche française ne soit pas
consciente de ce problème ou ne veuille
plus l'être peut-être pour des raisons
clientéliste parce qu'ils savent
parfaitement ce qu'ont connues dans les
paysages crois que les représentants de
la gauche comme je crois que c'est
vraiment un faux procès là en
l'occurrence on parle pas des pays
arabes on parle
la minorité musulmane qui vit en france
qui bien souvent est intégrée intégrée
et qui veut juste pratiquer encore une
fois sa religion vous avez une rencontre
un collectif qui se reproduit à moindre
échelle en france mais qui se reproduit
également mais aussi l'immense majorité
des musulmans français encore une fois
pratiquer leur foi en vivant très
tranquillement en république française
bien sûr c'est pour ça qu'il faut
empêcher les entreprises de certains
certaines formations mer ce qu'ils
veulent
s'ils voulaient marquer en quelque sorte
leur pouvoir notamment à travers ce
genre de vêtements merci beaucoup à tous
les deux
c'est tout l'objectif de cette émission
c'est de confronter des points de vue
différents pour que vous puissiez former
le vôtre merci d'avoir accepté cet
exercice et puis très bon week-end de
l'ascension à tous si vous le prenez
point de vue reviendra lundi et ce sera
toujours avec la même joie
merci
c'est vrai que c'est l'ascension
[Musique]